when it comes to ignoring human rights
and stifling free speech
well Egypt's added yet again over the
weekend three Al Jazeera journalists
were sentenced to three years in prison
for doing their jobs or if we go by the
judges words for spreading false news
the UN human rights organizations and
news groups around the world condemned
the sentences of vadym hem Mohamed Fahmy
and Peter greste who was tried in
absentia
Sammis lawyer amel clooney put it like
this the verdict today sends a very
dangerous message in Egypt it sends a
message that journalists can be locked
up for simply doing their job Clooney is
now urging Egyptian president Sisi to
pardon the charges but this is the same
man who since taking power two years ago
has overseen mass killings and a
tremendous crackdown on press freedom
and political dissent according to
Amnesty International more than 41,000
people have been arrested charged or
indicted with a criminal offence or
sentenced after unfair trials this
includes at least 18 imprisoned
journalists one of them is independent
photojournalist mahmoud abu zaid known
as show ken he's been held without trial
for more than 600 days the government
recently enacted a draconian
anti-terrorism law which brought into
the definition of terrorism and
penalizes journalists who don't tow the
government line amid all this
controversy the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs launched an english-language
blog to counter what it says our foreign
media's inaccurate reports about the
country but it's not just journalists on
the government's hit list others
arrested include human rights defenders
and well-known bloggers a lot of the
arrests occurred after Egypt's protests
law was instituted in November 2013 the
law allows authorities to arrest and
prosecute peaceful protesters and
criminalizes the very act of protesting
remember the famous mass protests in
Egypt in 2011 during the so-called Arab
Spring that led to the ouster of former
Hosni Mubarak well many of the young
activists who led those protests have
been swept up in mass arrests and are
still languishing behind bars so where
does the u.s. fit into all of this well
the u.s. gives Egypt 1.3 billion dollars
in military aid every year and considers
it a top ally in the Middle East in a
trip to Egypt in early August Secretary
of State John Kerry reiterated the
country's bond the importance of Egypt
and the importance of relationship can't
be understated and so your tax dollars
continue to flow to Egypt where
journalists are falsely accused and
protesters sit behind bars but don't
expect to see that on the foreign
ministry's new blog